alors avec nous monsieur jean petit
directeur adjoint de l'institut de
protection de sécurité nucléaire du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
monsieur petit d'abord at on mesuré en
france une radioactivité anormale
pas du tout mais aucun n'a aucune
augmentation du bruit de fond de la
radioactivité jusqu'à présent bon alors
vous avez entendu comme moi tout à
l'heure que les autorités soviétiques
donne un bilan de deux morts et que
l'agencé united press
elle donne un bilan de 2000 morts alors
est ce que ça ne paraît vraisemblable
à notre connaissance les deux mille
morts résulte d'un calcul et non pas de
témoignage de communiquer des
soviétiques d'un calcul fait en
accumulant des hypothèses ultra
pessimiste sur les niveaux de
radioactivité qui aurait pu être dégagée
je vois mal comment 2000 morts pas plus
qu'un comme l'a dit le docteur lafuma
tout à l'heure puisse être engendrés
même au voisinage immédiat par contre il
est vraisemblable que plusieurs
personnes plusieurs dizaines de
personnes peuvent avoir été gravement
blessée ou même tués par les effets
mécaniques vapeur vive incendie chute de
poutrelles d'un hangar et du bâtiment et
des choses ou basses qu'on ne meurt pas
immédiatement d'irradiation dans des
accidents de ce genre non me mourir une
bombe à te lis médiatement d'irradiation
6 aussi on est sous le champignon d'une
bo patriotiquement si je comprends bien
c'est ce grafite qui est utilisé pour le
processus de scission de l'atome a brûlé
et continue à brûler en ce moment et l'a
visiblement les soviétiques ne savent
pas comment l'arrêter
qu'est ce que c'est que ce graphique
exactement ce grafite qui
forment la majeure partie du coeur du
réacteur et au travers desquels
circulent les canaux de refroidissement
au bouillant sous pression et où sont
aussi les canaux de combustible est
présent dans des quantités très
importantes plusieurs centaines voire
plusieurs milliers de tonnes ce
graphique sert à modérer le neutron
c'est-à-dire allait ralentir de manière
à augmenter le rendement de fission
autrement dit augmenter le rendement
neutronique de la machine et ça veut
dire que si la 110e persiste il ya de
nouvelles matières radioactives qui
s'échappent dans l'atmosphère très
probablement probablement pas au avec la
même intensité que ce qui s'est passé
alors les accidents d'origine encore que
nous n'en connaissions pas les détails
mais il est très vraisemblable que de la
radioactivité continuent à ce choc et ça
veut dire que c'est dangereux non
seulement pour pour l'union soviétique
mais pour les pays avoisinants parce que
tout ça dépend de la météo après des
vents je ne pense pas que ça puisse
aller à une échelle
supérieur à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres aux alentours de la centrale
et donc a fortiori pas du tout au delà
des frontières de lire et de l'urss le
nuage père au fur et à mesure de sa
diffusion des activités en proportion
considérable
il faut que la population soit à
l'intérieur des maisons poids de
protéger ses soeurs au voisinage eu
l'une des mesures les plus efficaces si
on a à faire dans la dizaine ou 21 km
autour de la centrale à un passage de
nuages de ce genre l'une des mesures les
plus efficaces et le confinement dans
les habitations par simplement la
protection contre les radiations que
présentent les parois des murs des toits
des fenêtres même pouvant aller à une
réduction des doses pris jusqu'à des
facteurs pouvant atteindre 1000 façon là
la question que tout le monde s'est posé
qu'on a déjà posé d'ailleurs c'est un
accident ce type petit se produire en
france nous avons les centrales
nucléaires une fusion de coeur quoique
invraisemblable du fait de
l'accumulation des des précautions qui
sont prises n'a pas une probabilité 0 de
se produire ça n'existe pas la
probabilité nul ou la probabilité 1 dans
les disciplines scientifiques
ceci étant s'il se produisait les
dispositions prévues dans les plans
d'intervention autour des installations
nucléaires françaises sont elles que des
mesures comme le confinement de la
population ou l'évacuation dans des
zones situées de 5 à 10 km autour de la
centrale sont prévues par les pouvoirs
publics font l'objet de l'exercice
fréquent pour tester la réponse de
toutes les protections y compris les
protection sanitaire qui sont pas vus
dans ce cas alors la différence avec une
un accident qui s'est produit aux états
unis a three miles island c'est qu'il y
à un écrin dans les centrales
américaines
un écrin qui donc empêche les produits
radioactifs dans l'atmosphère c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
enceinte de confinement qui est une
enceinte étanche et résistante à la
pression
composé d'une peau intérieure en acier
et
d'un massif de béton très épais qui
existe dans toutes les centrales
utilisé en france aux états unis et dans
les pays de l'ouest en général et qui
n'était pas présente dans c'est vraiment
su hauteur as oui nous en avons une
quasi certitude mais à three mile island
la radioactivité considérable puisque
une partie très importante du coeur a
fondu à three mile island a été
entièrement contenue dans cette enceinte
les émissions à l'extérieur et donc les
conditions et les conséquences
sanitaires étant strictement nul mais là
bon ces produits radioactifs par exemple
à three mile island reste dans cet écrin
mais qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent après
et bien une bonne partie des croise avec
la décroissance naturel de la
radioactivité
pour ceux dont la période est la plus
longue
guesdon qui serait plus difficile de se
débarrasser avec le temps on peut
contrôler et filtrer les rejets à très
très petite quantité en l'étalant sur
des mois des mois et des mois de manière
à les rendre totalement inoffensif
monsieur petit on peut pas dire que ce
soit quand même un accident de ce genre
même si ce produit en union soviétique
et dans une centrale qui n'est pas une
centrale que nous possédons du type que
nous possédons on peut quand même pas
dire que ce soit une bonne publicité
pour le nucléaire
certains noms c'est c'est un mauvais
point pour l'image de marque du
nucléaire en général de celui de l'union
soviétique en particulier et il est
certain que les soviétiques devront
remettre en question un certain nombre
de choses de même que nous devons faire
des examens de conscience aux plans 2d
des enseignements que nous devrons
pyrèthre ce type d'incident je remercie
beaucoup monsieur jean petit je rappelle
que vous êtes le directeur adjoint de
l'institut de protection de sécurité
nucléaire au commissariat à l'énergie
atomique
l'ancien